[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute würde ich gerne ein thema
ansprechen was bei uns wirklich sehr
aktuell ist nämlich medienkonsum und
kinder und in unserem fall eben auch
unsere kinder ist wirklich ein sehr
aktuelles thema ich rede mit vielen
eltern darüber mit vielen freunden
darüber wie und ob die kinder ein handy
bekommen wann sie es bekommen wann sie
unser handy benutzen dürfen
und wir haben für uns einfach eine
lösung gefunden ich erkläre es später
und zwar haben wir die youtube kids für
uns entdeckt samira darf zum beispiel
die app auch benutzen wenn sie
hausaufgaben macht das heißt so zum
mathe lernen oder adjektiven omen
da gibt es einfach viele songs und viele
singen lieder und lernen lieder die sie
sich dann wirklich gut einprägen kann
und sie kann dann auf kindliche art und
weise ihre interessen erforschen und
entdecken und es trotzdem keiner gefahr
ausgesetzt weil ich eben kontrollieren
kann was sie sich da an schaute und vor
allem wie lange und zwar funktioniert
das ganze dann so ihr registriert euch
praktisch als eltern und erstellt ein
konto und dann könnt ihr verschiedene
profile anlegen ich habe zum beispiel
ein profil für samira angelegt und eins
für ella weil einfach alle andere
interessen hat als ihre große schwester
samira jetzt nämlich so samira endlich
setzt sich wirklich sehr fürs malen fürs
tanzen aber auch fürs basteln und bist
kreativ sein
sie nutzt die app eben auch um zu lernen
zum beispiel hat sie das einmaleins
matte den mathe song gelernt und sich so
praktisch das einmaleins gemerkt und
dann könnt ihr wirklich bestimmen was
sie sehen darf und was nicht
man bekommt auch viele dinge
vorgeschlagen das heißt kein
medienexperte oder medienpädagoge sein
und selber herausfiltern was passt zu
meinem kind
ihr könnt aber auch sagen wenn euch ganz
persönlich ein kanal nicht gefällt könnt
ihr diesen einfach sperren sodass das
kind keinen zugriff auf den kanal hat
und was ich auch ganz gut finde
ihr könnt einsehen was euer kind gesehen
hat also die historie praktisch und ihr
könnt dann eben auch noch gerne die zeit
einstellen also sagen okay medien konsum
ist auf 30 minuten limitiert pro tag
oder auf 60 minuten und ich würde auch
wirklich immer ganz ganz wenig starten
dass der medienkonsum auch so gering wie
möglich halten und später kann man es
dann mit steigendem alter eben auch
erhöhen
ihr könnt dann auch ganz einfach eine
playlist erstellen so habe ich zum
beispiel eine playlist von super simple
songs für ella
da lernt sie dann die englischen
bewegungslieder und die lern liter es
hat aber auch die deutsche playlist wo
sie dann songs von simone sommer land
zum beispiel lernt so etwas wie kopf
schulter knie und fuß und sich eben
singen und dazu bewegen kann und die
samira die hat eine playlist vontobel
lotte wo sie wirklich basteln kann und
aber auch andere plänen ist so schön
zeichnet und eben auch die matte songs
lernt und anna dieser vier jahre alt sie
kann also noch nicht lesen und schreiben
und die app ist so aufgebaut dass sie
wirklich kinderleicht zu bedienen ist
mit extragroßen symbol aber eben auch
per sprachsteuerung also kann sie
einfach sagen was sie auf der es sehen
will und dann kommen eben auch genau
diese inhalte
bei uns ist es grad momentan so samira
ist in der dritten klasse neun jahre alt
und das thema medien ist halt wirklich
aktuell vor allem gerade bei uns im
haushalt ist es halt wirklich so ich
arbeite mit dem handy das heißt ich habe
ständig bei mir murat ist ständig am
handy
wir kommentieren eure kommentare
natürlich machen wir viel auf instagram
facebook und youtube also wir nutzen
wirklich alle sozialen plattformen und
das handy ist bei uns zumindest aus dem
alltag nicht mehr wegzudenken ist
natürlich andererseits ganz schwierig
weil ich natürlich auch für meine kinder
ein gutes vorbild sein will und eben
auch sagen hey das handy ist klar für
uns für die arbeit auch wichtig für uns
privat aber eben nicht so wichtig aber
die kinder sehen die kinder lernen sie
wollen natürlich auch ans handy sie
wollen auch sich etwas anschauen und es
ist wirklich ein thema was finde ich zu
wenig thematisiert wird vor allem
öffentlich oder auch in der schule und
momentan bei uns ist so in der dritten
klasse geht es wirklich auch schon
einige kinder den handy haben
ich bin da muss ich sagen komplett
dagegen ich meine wir fahren unsere
tochter zur schule unserem kindergarten
holen sie auch wieder ab weil wir eben
auch in einem industriegebiet wohnen das
heißt die schule ist jetzt nicht so
direkt auf den laufweg zu erreichen und
deswegen denke ich mir halt immer sie
brauchen gar kein handy in der schule
denn sie kann ja wenn was passiert
einfach ins sekretariat und ebendort
dann bei uns anrufen lassen und daher
habe ich auch zum montag wir haben
gemeinsam beschlossen unsere tochter
bekommt erstmal kein handy vor allem
nicht in diesen jungen jahren
ich weiß nicht ob sie es ändert wenn sie
vielleicht in der fünften klasse ist und
auf eine andere schule wechseln
vielleicht mit dem bus weiter weg fahren
muss denkt ich würde ich eher aus
sicherheitsgründen
handy kaufen einfach damit zu uns
erreichen kann wenn man der bus ausfällt
oder wenn sie früher schule aus hart wo
weiß auch verlässliche grundschule gibt
oder verlässliche schule ja aber es war
wirklich so ein thema und natürlich hat
sie jetzt zu hause kein handy aber das
thema ist halt immer mama kriege ich mal
dein handy mama kann ich mal als ipad
haben und es ist halt wirklich so ich
glaube man kann es vielleicht so
vergleichen
normalerweise wird mir auch nicht sein
kind nehmen und einfach irgendwie in die
nächstgrößere großstadt gehen und auf
der straße aus setzen und sagen okay
jazz bis später macht dann einfach mal
ich mein mann beschützt ja auch sein
kind so im echten leben und sorgt dafür
dass es eben in einem sicheren umfeld
ist und gerade am handy sind wirklich zu
wenig eltern die gucken was die kinder
machen und das internet ist groß das
internet ist weit und wenn man da nicht
drüber schaut kann es echt oft passieren
dass die kinder einfach inhalte sehen
die nicht für sie geeignet sind und
youtube ist für mich so eine plattform
auf youtube habe ich meinen kanal
großgezogen und youtube hat den vorteil
dass wirklich jeder videos hochladen
kann
das heißt jeder hat eine stimme jeder
kann zeigen was für ein tolles talent er
hat jeder kann lehr videos hochladen
aber genau dieses offen diese offene
plattform ist natürlich auch im nachteil
denn es sind natürlich auch inhalte drin
die vielleicht jetzt nicht gerade für
vier jahre gesehen sollte oder eine 78
jährige
und genau so könnt ihr es nämlich auch
sehen youtube ist eben diese großstadt
wo es einfach alles gibt das heißt ich
interessiere mich vielleicht eher für
die backstube fürs kochen und backen
ich interessiere mich noch für die kunst
murat ist er so auf dem heimwerker kanal
und schaut sich er diese dinge an und
meine kinder die sollen sich eigentlich
lieber in der bibliothek aufhalten oder
auf dem spielplatz und natürlich gibt's
auch eltern die sagen wisst ihr was ich
will mit dem ganzen internet gar nichts
zu tun haben
meine kinder sollen draußen spielen und
gar nicht mit handys oder mit anderen
medien in verbindung kommen oder in
kontakt kommen verstehe ich auch aber
man muss man wirklich sagen wir leben
gerade in der zeit da ist es wirklich
nicht mehr wegzudenken und die kinder
können überall wirklich von überall aus
aufs internet zugreifen und ich finde
wenn man zu hause nicht mit den kindern
bespricht und gerade wir als elternteil
nicht dafür sorge tragen was sie dort
sehen und wie lange sie sich darauf
halten das ganze aber auch in der schule
nicht thematisiert wird weil es die
politik hat immer noch nicht geschafft
hat
medien zu einem pflichtfach gemacht wird
dann haben die kinder einfach kein
ansprechpartner
dann seid ihr zu hause und sagt okay bei
uns ist es verboten in der schule haben
die lehrkräfte gar keine zeit das thema
anzusprechen weil sie einfach ihren
ganzen lerninhalte den ganzen schulstoff
und alles andere unterbringen müssen und
dann stehen die kinder da haben keine
hilfe keinen ansprechpartner und wenn
sie dann mit dem gerät mit dem handy in
verbindung kommen und irgendwas
unangebrachtes sehen haben sie keinen an
den sie sich wenden
und ich finde es ist wirklich eine große
lücke und vor allem auch eine große
gefahrenquelle weil sie dann wenn sie in
so einem kreis erst mal drin sind auch
angst haben mich anzusprechen wenn sie
eben was verboten das machen oder was
verbotenes sehen und deswegen finde ich
es einfach umso wichtiger dass er mit
euren kindern spricht dass er ihnen
zeigt was ihr tun dürfen was sie tun
können und was ja auch alles kreatives
damit erleben können und ich will jetzt
nicht damit sagen holt eure kinder und
setzt sie vors handy sondern ich möchte
einfach nur damit sagen wenn eure kinder
schon daran interesse haben dann solltet
ihr zumindest wissen was sie tun was sie
anschauen und vor allem wie lange es ist
anschauen ich mein kind mit eineinhalb
zwei jahren muss man nicht unbedingt
videos anschauen lassen das finde ich
jetzt auch überflüssig aber ich muss
auch dazu sagen dass meine kinder
zumindest gerade über youtube eben auch
songs gelernt haben die eller zum
beispiel die sind englische lieder weil
sie gerne super simpel songs hört macht
bewegungsspiele dazu oder samira hatten
wir damals schon mit vier viereinhalb
jahren ein türkisches lied vorgesungen
über die sinnesorgane
da stand der murat da und hat sagt woher
weiß nie was heißt was heißt das
überhaupt und sie hat uns praktisch auf
türkisch die sinnesorgane erklärt weil
sie den song eben gehört hat oder samira
bastelt und wird kreativ weil sie sich
den tobi lotter kanal anschaut bastelt
raketen oder kleine einhörner oder keine
deko elemente für ihr kinderzimmer oder
die ela macht bewegungsspiele weil sie
gerne simone sommer land hört jetzt
übrigens richtig tolle kinderlieder und
kinder bewegungslieder die wir dann auch
gerne auf kindergeburtstagen hören und
das sind einfach dinge wo man dann
praktisch diese youtube nutzen kann
damit kinder eben auch was lernen ein
wirklich sehr aktuell das thema worüber
wirklich immer diskutiert wird auch und
mich würde interessieren wie handhabt
ihr das zu hause mit medienkonsum mit
dem handy haben eure kinder handys wenn
ja ab wie viel jahren
ich glaube dass es wirklich so
thema gibt es pauschal keine richtige
lösung sondern jeder muss für sich
selbst zu hause entscheiden was ist für
uns das beste und bei uns ist es einfach
so wir haben sie jetzt wirklich so mit
der youtube kids einfach geregelt dass
wir sagen okay er hat diese inhalte
samira die inhalte die zeit wurde
festgelegt und ich weiß einfach was die
kinder machen was sie sich anschauen und
vor allem eben auch wie lange aber
kommentiert doch jetzt einfach unter
diesem video was ihr von diesem thema
haltet ich bin jetzt auch den nächsten
stunden noch online und werden eure
kommentare dann zurück kommentieren so
kann ich mir vielleicht noch ein paar
tipps und tricks abgeschaut und
natürlich auch andere und ich denke es
ist einfach so bei uns auch so ich
vergleiche es mit süßigkeiten bei samira
als sie das erste kind war war es
nämlich so dass ich wirklich süßigkeiten
gar nicht zu hause hatte und erst als
sie drei war und in der großen
kindergartengruppe dann praktisch
süßigkeiten zu kindergeburtstagen zum
beispiel da waren wusste sie aha es gibt
etwas das nennt sich schokolade und es
ist süß schmeckt und bei ella war es
aber so dass sie schon relativ früh dann
mit süßigkeiten in kontakt kam weil eben
das große geschwisterkind schon dabei
war und so ist es eben auch mit den
medien gewesen also samira kam ein
bisschen später dran
er war natürlich etwas früher weil die
große schwester ihr das natürlich auch
vorlebt und ich glaube da gibt es
bestimmt auch hilfreiche tipps und
tricks von euch von denen ich lernen
kann
deswegen schreibt in die kommentare
lasst uns gemeinsam darüber diskutieren
und eure meinung würde mich wirklich
sehr interessieren also ich hoffe euch
hat das wieder spaß gemacht und ich
hoffe dass einige eltern sich wirklich
ein bisschen gedanken machen über den
medienkonsum schaut auf jeden fall nicht
wegschaut was eure kinder machen das
wirklich nämlich super wichtig dass sie
einen ansprechpartner haben in der
schule aber eben auch zu hause also bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]